are there any policy solutions
either at a local or federal level that
excite you
right now that would start solving a lot
of the issues you
have pointed out for decades yeah i mean
well
someone very basic one i said i signed a
petition yesterday i think is that
no way i mean just to show you how low
level this can be but how crucial
uh facebook wants instagram for children
under 12.
no that is not a good idea i'm just to
show you how granular you can get when
you actually start thinking
about this like where could technology
hurt me tomorrow
that's a good exercise for everybody to
do instead of thinking oh my god let me
think of some tech policy
where could technology hurt me tomorrow
and hurt the things i care about most
tomorrow i bet there's somebody in the
tech industry planning that very thing
to get people invested in policy you
have to stop
thinking oh policy is like for people in
washington am i no
policy is things that are about you and
your family think of the thing
that really could screw you up tomorrow
what would your recommendation be to
families whether it's parents or just
individuals like myself like hey
tech is like i have like problems paying
attention
tech makes that 10 times worse it it
hurts me
um what would you recommend
that people can do now in their daily
lives right to make their own reality
better
i have a simple list the car
dinner the car dinner
food car dinner food no tech
and when you're in the car with children
or with your friends
you say to them conversation is so
precious
talk to me when you're in the car with
your children if you have children
and they dave that's when they really
want you to do social media you say you
know
we have so little time to talk i
shouldn't be texting in the car
this is the time i really want to talk
to you
i'm your parent hate me later food
preparation
when we're preparing food in my home we
don't use the phone
and then bedroom i mean the number of
couples who are who are texting while
they're in bed getting ready to be in
bed making love
have a notion of sacred space it's not a
religious notion it's a
make up your own idea of sacred places
in the house where they can go
where their phones don't and you could
go there once a day you go
there once every two days i'm not
telling you how much you should go there
but it's some place where you don't
bring your phone and then it gives you
an
opportunity to see
what can i think about when my phone
isn't there
it gives you an opportunity to ask
yourself that question i wonder what
ideas come to me when my phone isn't
around but i don't make any rules about
how much television you should watch i
love television and when i watch
television with my family we talk we
talk to the television we make comments
that's true yeah it can be really
connecting yeah so my girlfriend
um she loves when
we have car time i'm not living in new
york city we don't have a car but in the
pandemic we would take
rent a car and take road trips um and
she loved it because for me with a like
slight add i have something to focus on
i can focus on and then i can still have
walking's good too but the car and you
know she's got five hours i can't go
anywhere where you have to have a deep
conversation
um and i enjoy it because i get to know
her better and i get some you know you
get to know yourself better when you
have a good conversation
um so i love that and one thing i love
about your field and your work is it's
been my problem with academics and look
we need
academics in general this research and
this stuff is so so so important but
there's such brilliant research out
there that doesn't get connected to
practice
um and by definition your work has to be
put into practice
because it's literally you're like
studying the practice you're studying
the human
like execution and interaction with
technology um so i love that
thank you card dinner food or car
food bedroom however you want to slice
that i'm so curious at this
trajectory you've been on because you've
been writing about tech and humanity
and researching tech community teaching
technology humanity for
you know for years and you then
recently and i'm assuming this was a
covid project it may be started before
but you became
you wrote a memoir it's called the
empathy diaries
you wrote a completely different book um
about your own personal journey why the
shift why did you go
that way um to to kind of further your
your efforts and vision here the book
began
began when after i wrote my first
book on computers and people which was
called the second self was 1984
and i was holding on to a family secret
that my the person who i said was my
father was not my father
my mother didn't want anyone to know
that she had been divorced and that i
had a secret father
and she would never talk to me about why
she just said we're never going to talk
about him
and you're going to have to have a
different name and like i i
first i mean i used to go to one school
and i had to write my real name because
it was my
legal name and then i would travel to a
different neighborhood and hide my books
i was the secret agent
i was a little jewish brooklyn secret
agent
and um my interest in empathy began
by trying to figure out why would my
mother do this the nancy drew of my own
life
my i publish this book i get onto the
cover of esquire magazine they come to
write an article about me
and this very nice interviewer asks me
so i just read the second cells it's
like super brilliant you're super
brilliant
you thank your mom who's died you know a
million times
but you don't say anything about your
father so who's your dad what did he do
you know
and i behave i'm like oh i do like a
diva like
oh no i can't discuss that i can only
discuss my work i i never discussed my
personal life no no i you know
i behave like a super crazy person like
a super crazy person
and he walked out and of course in
esquire magazine he writes about that
i'm a little crazy which was like
very painful he says something like well
you know her brand is the
uh is the thought and feeling or
integrated but if you ask her a question
that asks
about thought and feeling she freaks out
it's so painful to see that stuff in
writing too
even though it doesn't fully matter it's
it matters at the time
i just was like he's right he's right
i've been holding this family secret for
for four decades
what is this you know what or three
decades what is this
so i um i i literally i saw him walk out
the door i knew what was going to happen
i called up my half sister and brother
i told him the truth i called up milton
turkle
and who was this stepfather who i'd been
lying about i said i'm it's over
you know nothing i haven't done anything
wrong there's nothing so horrible in my
life that i need to hide there
i said i am just free
and then i had to figure out
how this very particular
um background it was clear to me
that this very particular background of
trying to figure out all of these
people's motivations
had sort of set me up in some way
and had i had turned lemon into lemonade
it had
turned me into the kinds of into the
kind of
person who could do the work i was doing
and i wanted to write that book so i've
been writing that this book since really
in 1984
you've said this a number of ways in
order to have empathy for others you
have to have empathy for yourself
and understand it did you once you
started having empathy
for yourself did your
research and the academic and the the
hard aspects of the
technology and how we function as humans
did that all just crystallize it
was it was it easier did you see a
research from a different lens there to
make you better
at what you do like how did that impact
it it really did
because i was able to um just function
at a higher level i became more
um everything about me
and of course that there were other
things going on in my life i was in a
psychoanalyst had
life experiences i became older i mean
so many things happen it wasn't a
controlled experiment but
i think that really the close
examination of your life and coming to
terms with the
forces that have gotten you to do
the passionate work that you do
make you better at your work uh
because i was able to approach my work
with distance i was able to
uh um
and a kind of lightness i could see my
stake in it i could be more distant from
it
i was more compassionate with my in
other words i'm you know when
it's like uh as i tell my students you
know
uh in work you have ups and downs some
experiments don't work some books don't
work some
papers don't get published them you know
make sure you love the journey
and this book you know and and my work
the better i understood my work and the
better i understood the importance of my
work
because there's been many years in which
i've been pitching this story about
computers changing the way we think and
people
just said to me that is no stupid thing
you know computer's a tool
why are you doing this this is like what
a
this is really not the thing and i just
have to love the work
you know and i have to know how it
connects to my life and i have to know
how it's
really a an expression of my
it's it is my it's my
it's my it's the true expression of my
talents
[Music]
you